buenas noches han advertido que las
semanas siguientes esos contagios van a
seguir creciendo a niveles récords y
probablemente veremos un panorama no
antes visto desde que arrancó la
pandemia aquí en el reino unido- las
hospitalizaciones en todo el país
también están creciendo en un 10% y es
que la los contagios por la variante
omicron está creciendo un ritmo
absolutamente fenomenal ha dicho esta
noche el jefe científico del gobierno el
profesor kruijswijk y solo para
mostrarles la gravedad de la situación
el 60 por ciento de los casos aquí en
londres ya son de esta variante
mientras la jefe también de la agencia
científica y médica del reino unido ha
dicho que o micrones probablemente la
amenaza más significativa que hemos
tenido desde el comienzo de la pandemia
porque los casos en el país ya se están
duplicando cada dos o tres días y el
llamado a la población días antes de las
fiestas de navidad es que limite el
contacto para seguir y en frenar los
contagios luisa a contarnos cómo impactó
esto en el gobierno británico tomarán
medidas adicionales de algún tipo
no de momento el primer ministro boris
johnson en una rueda de prensa que
ofreció esta noche desde downing street
ha dicho que no se hacen necesarias que
el plan b es suficiente por el momento y
que a diferencia de la navidad de
diciembre de 2020 la hacen las vacunas
por ello llamó a que la población reciba
la tercera dosis ya aquí en el reino
unido- todos los adultos sobre los 18
años son elegibles para esta tercera
dosis de hecho dijo que el 40 por ciento
de la población ya ha recibido esas tres
dosis tiene una meta bien ambiciosa
boris johnson y dos vacunar a toda la
población sobre los 18 años antes de que
termine este
2021 lo que significa que cada millón
cada día habría que vacunar un millón de
personas hasta el momento no se ha
alcanzado esa meta entretanto
organizaciones científicas y médicas
insisten en que estas proyecciones que
se han hecho de parte de las agencias y
steve científicas obligarían a tomar
nuevas medidas pero el gobierno de
momento ha dicho no esto todo se da en
medio de una crisis de credibilidad que
afronta el primer ministro que ayer en
el parlamento vivió una rebelión de 100
de los diputados de su propio partido